So, I'm here with Sebastian, and Junior,
one of Sebastian's self driving cars.
Sebastian is going to give an idea of how rich inputs and outputs can be
by talking about the kinds of inputs and outputs that he has on the self-driving car.
[Sebastian] So, taking data in is essential to making self-driving cars work.
This machine has a lot of sensors that take data in at enormous rates.
There is a laser range finder on the roof that rotates.
And it takes scans 10 times a second of the entire surroundings or range scans.
It has a security camera, very much like Google Street who's able to see in all directions.
In fact, this camera played an important role in Google Street's history
and then it has stereo camera system, and also has a GPS system
that we use to localize the car course [inaudible] based on satellite navigation.
So, all this data, which are millions and millions of data points per second,
get fed into the computer system that sits in the robot's trunk.
So, this is the data. This is the laser data, but a million points per second.
And you can see in his 3-dimensional depiction, the robot is parked in the garage,
it sees the back wall, and it can see all kinds of other things around it.
It uses that exact same data to avoid collisions with other cars, bicycles, pedestrians, and so on.
And finally, the data gets funneled back to the car. These are the outputs of the computer system.
And they go into the car: four little switches over here.
They actuate the steering wheel; they use the brake, the gas.
You can't really see it? It looks like a regular car; and it is.
But if I hit this one button over here, it turns into a self-driving car.